>>> HERE IS THE BREAKING NEWS
THAT I'M GETTING IN RIGHT NOW.
BOBBY FLAY IS GOING DOWN, DOWN,
DOWN!
>> OH MY GOD.
>> WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
THE OCTOBER JOBS REPORT, ONE
INDUSTRY THAT CONTINUES TO FACE
DIRE STAFFING SHORTAGES, THAT'S
RESTAURANTS.
COMPETITION FOR WORKERS REMAIN
INTENSE -- REMAINS INTENSE.
ABOUT TWO-THIRDS OF RESTAURANTS
SAY THEY ARE UNDERSTAFFED,
ACCORDING TO AN INDUSTRY SURVEY.
THEN THERE'S THE SOARING FOOD
PRICES, SUPPLY CHAINS, LOG JAMS
AND SO FOR THE.
JOINING US, A MAN WHO KNOWS WHAT
IT TAKES TO RUN A RESTAURANT,
CHEF, ENTREPRENEUR, MY FRIEND
BOBBY FLAY.
HIS NEW SHOW PREMIERES TUESDAY
ON THE FOOD NETWORK.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR BOBBY FLAY TO
INVITE ALL THREE OF US ON YOUR
PROGRAM.
>> NO PROBLEM.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
>> AS YOU'RE WATCHING THE JOBS
REPORTS, DOES ANYTHING RESONATE
WITH YOU?
>> OH, YEAH.
THE THING ABOUT RESTAURANTS,
IT'S AN EVERY NIGHT FOCUS GROUP
ABOUT HOW PEOPLE ARE FEELING
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS IT'S GETTING
SQUEEZED FROM EVERY SORT OF
CORNER AND EDGE.
LABOR'S EXPENSIVE, COMMODITIES
MEANING THE COST OF GOODS,
FOODS, ET CETERA, IS EXPENSIVE.
AND OCCUPANCY COSTS ARE ALWAYS
EXPENSIVE.
THE LANDLORDS DOESN'T LOOK OUT
FOR YOU.
THEY DON'T TAKE THE PRESSURE
OFF.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, I THINK THE
CONSUMER UNDERSTAND WE'RE ON THE
BRINK OF SOME REALLY BAD ECONOMY
HERE SO PEOPLE TIGHTEN THEIR
WALLET.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT, WE'RE ON
THE BRING OF A BAD ECONOMY?
>> THEY SAY THAT.
>> I DO.
I'VE BEEN AROUND LONG ENOUGH TO
SEE THIS HAPPEN BEFORE.
AND ULTIMATELY WE'RE ABLE TO
COME OUT OF IT BUT YOU DO HAVE
TO HOLD ON TIGHT.
I FEEL LIKE SOMETHING NOT GOOD
IS HAPPENING.
YOU LOOK AT ALL THE REPORT AND I
WATCH THE WAY PEOPLE ARE ACTING
IN THE RESTAURANT.
>> MEANING --
>> THE PERSON LAST WEEK WAS
BUYING $75 BOTTLE OF WINE, THIS
WEEK IT'S A $40 BOTTLE OF WINE.
THEY'RE MAKING DECISIONS THAT
ARE SQUEEZING THE CHECK HOURS IN
THE RESTAURANT.
IT MAKES IT VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF IT, THE
PROPRIETOR IS HAVING A HARD TIME
MAKING PROFITS.
SO PEOPLE THAT WANT TO COME BACK
TO WORK, THEY WANT HIGHER
SALARIES OF COURSE AND YOU HAVE
TO BE VERY COMPETITIVE TO GET
GOOD LABOR.
>> AND WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
ARE YOU ABLE TO FIND PEOPLE?
I'VE HEARD THIS IS A BIG ISSUE
OF EVERYONE THAT WAS LEFT GO BY
RESTAURANTS AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC, THEY'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTY HIRING GOOD PEOPLE
BACK.
>> WE ALL SAID AND I SAY "WE"
MEANING MY FRIENDS IN THE
BUSINESS, WHERE IS EVERYBODY?
YOU THOUGHT THE PANDEMIC HIT AND
EVERYBODY WOULD BE WILLING TO
COME BACK TO WORK RIGHT AWAY BUT
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN.
WE BASICALLY OPENED THE DOORS
AND WONDERED WHERE EVERYBODY
WAS.
NOW PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO
TRICKLE BACK BUT, AGAIN, IT'S
VERY, VERY COMPETITIVE.
>> BOBBY AND I LIVE OUT ON LONG
ISLAND.
AND YOU KNOW THAT RESTAURANT
ALMOND --
>> I LOVE THAT RESTAURANT.
>> PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO PROVIDE
HOUSING FOR EMPLOYEES BECAUSE
IT'S TOUGH.
THERE ARE INCENTIVES, YOU'RE
HAVING TO PAY PEOPLE BONUSES.
>> BONUSES, BENEFITS, ANYTHING
TO MAKE PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THIS IS
THE PLACE I WANT TO WORK.
AND ALSO LIKE, YOU KNOW, THE
PROBLEM IS IF SOMEBODY COMES BY
AND OFFERS YOUR EMPLOYEE AN
EXTRA DOLLAR AN HOUR, THAT ADDS
UP OVER THE WEEK AND YEAR.
YOU HAVE TO DO THINGS THAT ARE
NOT JUST ABOUT THE ACTUAL
DOLLARS THEMSELVES TO MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY WANT TO
STAY IN YOUR RESTAURANT.
>> WHAT CAN ECONOMIC LEARN FROM
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY?
WHAT CAN YOU TEACH THEM?
>> I CAN TELL YOU ONE THING, THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO BE
PAYING FOR THIS IS THE
CONSUMERS.
RESTAURANT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
KEEP CHARGING MORE MONEY TO
SURVIVE SO THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY CREATE JOBS.
AND ALSO SURVIVE AS A PROPRIETOR
AS WELL.
IT'S A VICIOUS CYCLE AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE.
I SAY WE'RE LITERALLY A
GENERATION AWAY OF PEOPLE
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT REALLY
COSTS TO GO EAT IN A RESTAURANT
AND BE OKAY WITH IT.
ALL OF US PAY OR OWN BILLS.
WE KNOW CHICKEN COSTS $24 IN OUR
FAVORITE RESTAURANT.
WHAT IF I TOLD YOU IT'S GOING TO
BE $38 NEXT WEEK?
SOMEBODY WHO IS 16 YEARS OLD WHO
IS NOT PAYING THEIR BILLS YET,
THEY'RE GOING TO BE COMFORTABLE
PAYING THAT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THEY SEE AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
KNOW.
>> ALL OF THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BUT WE HAVE SOMETHING
MORE IMPORTANT, WHICH IS WHEN
DON LEMON WAS ON YOUR SHOW.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHEN LIFE GIVES YOU DON
LEMON, YOU MAKE LEMONADE, BABY.
I WATCH YOU ALL THE TIME.
YOU HAVE THIS THING WHERE YOU
TAKE A MOMENT AND SAY WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK.
>> CAN I REMIND YOU THERE'S
SOMEONE ELSE OUT THERE LIKE
THAT?
>> ME?
>> YOU.
>> WHAT DID DON LEMON COOK AND
WAS IT GOOD?
>> DON DIDN'T COOK, HE JUST
TRIED TO GET ME BEAT.
>> I SAW ALEX THE OTHER NIGHT AT
ALBA IN THE CITY.
I TRY TO SUPPORT LOCAL
RESTAURANTS.
>> I'M GLAD DON HAS FIGURED OUT
A WAY TO GO OUT TO DINNER ON
THIS SCHEDULE.
>> FOR EIGHT AND A HALF YEARS I
DID NOT REALLY GET TO GO OUT AND
HAVE A PROPER DINNER BECAUSE I
HAD A SHOW ON AT 10:00.
NOW I CAN GO TO DINNER.
IT'S EXPENSIVE!
>> AND IT'S GOING TO GET MORE
EXPENSIVE, DON.
THAT'S THE LESSON OF THE DAY.
>> SHE HELD UP A MIRROR TO YOU
AND YOU ALSO HELD UP A MIRROR TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN CHARGE OF
US, OF THE ECONOMY AND WHAT HAVE
YOU ABOUT WHAT IS TO COME AND A
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE ABOUT IT.
>> LISTEN, WE'LL GET THROUGH
THIS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT NOBODY
KNOWS WHEN AND HOW LONG AND HOW
DEEP IT GOING TO